welcome to this video on round five of
the candidates tournament this is a new
feature of the coverage because I got
some comments on the videos for Round
four which really worth Ted long I I
agree with that so when this video is
providing a quick overview of what
happened in this round you still have
the form single game videos for
intensive detailed coverage this is just
an added bonus if you only have like 20
minutes on your hands you can watch this
video to know what happens today but if
you want to yeah really um yeah get into
the details you can still watch the
single game video so let's get going to
really make it a short video alright
first game to look at kayaking
Mammadyarov both players not in great
shape minus one they need to get
something going let's see what happened
I think later before we hit the Bishop
b5 line of the decision and we got to
this typical maroc see bind structure
with c4 ID for and yeah there are some
ways for y to generate some play mostly
connected with keeping pieces on the
board rookie 1c1 yeah maybe f3 just keep
pieces on the board but kayaking
surprisingly goes for 95 after which
Mammadyarov can exchange all the lights
pieces here all the minor pieces and get
counter play with b5 and it seems that
this play that white has with priming
rookie one on the foul and blacks play
against the pawn it seems that this play
more or less some cancels each other out
why term piled up on this week porn only
seven as we see
and black gets the counterclaim against
e4 yeah white can take him but that the
end this will not lead to much the sea
poorness simply too weak and yeah he
tried to win the apron which member
geroll just gave away but as a
compensation he got this active Queen
and active rook and it turned out that
blacks counterplay is some simply too
big him he can always attack here attack
here and with this and d5 is an
additional weakness um there is simply
nothing to do here besides trading off
more chances just what they did and
after those moves they agreed to a draw
yeah somewhat boring game but in the
longer video you get some ideas in the
opening the opening phase two maybe if
you play this is why to maintain a slide
initiative there are ways to maybe a
play it in a bit more aggressive fashion
and I'm trying to show this in the in
the longer video yeah not not too
exciting for the whole tournament
standing this games both players stay on
minus one and couldn't couldn't really
improve okay next game is son Drake in
anand we have the the leader island plus
two against I draken who is an in bad
shape he already has some lost two games
and yeah he really needs to needs a win
badly I think to really get into the
tournament let's see what what happened
here the Berlin defense yeah should I
don't play something sharper to really I
don't know yeah 22 to fight the guy
who's in bad shape it's hard to tell I
mean you can try for something sharper
but
also you can get your servant to travel
with that I think it's just going for a
solid approach and hopes for form and
raking from yeah 22 just yeah except the
battle in a way and not play a very
draws line yeah in fact this is what he
did and raking played a solid line this
setup which is certainly not yeah very
exciting but it at least keeps some
pieces on the board it's not like a
completely drawn position we am got some
struggle on the queenside white was
tried with a 4 + B form this on the
board while black girl has a solid
position in the center and long-term
might can do something against this
response here we should be 792 b6
dissolve quite normal looking and white
try to do something on the a file with a
5 yeah island is just setting up a solid
position and lets white enter on a 7 he
just believes that his position is solid
enough and this is probably true he just
played rook c8 to defense e7 rook a one
and now be fine but here's an
interesting spot the most one of the
interesting spots in the game Black now
has a threat really and this is nigh day
for something that white needs to attend
to if you place and nothing moves that
night a form is already getting tricky
look at this here the rook is actually
trapped something like that might easily
happen white needs to do something
against nine a four and he went for
deform oops he went for deform a drastic
solution queen bee for us actually might
suggest it improvement I think this is
easier to handle but ok deform and here
I've got the e4 pawn in exchange for the
c7 pawn
in the resulting structure it seems that
black has slightly the better chances if
you look at this this Bishop is just
stronger than the night it has some
potential to damage whites pawn
structure and the sea porn is also under
fire by the Queen can easily be improved
with attack by the rook and after some
more moves we see that a lot simply has
the more active position and I believe
that in the further course of the game
and this is exactly here he could have
set and raking really difficult problems
also noting that he had much more time
on the clock I think we never won here
was yeah what's really making it
difficult for why to defend king g3 and
then rook e8 intending rookie tomb and
after that white needs to defend very
very accurately and I believe this would
have been very tough one Drake in to
manage with limited time um amount
however played rugby 5 also an
attractive-looking move but wife has a
defense and this is what Andre keen
blade is king queen to d3 this is
covering this critical square and black
now really does not have much else than
to trade Queens you can keep the Queen's
on the board if you like but it's not
really doing much the white king will
retreat and then there's simply not much
left to fight for this also 33 coming so
what black needed to do was to use this
temporary problem of the king and he
didn't do it yeah now we traded Queens
and this is just the drawn endgame white
can easily toss the D phone for activity
and who's you just check I have those
porns traded yeah here they already
agreed to a draw it's it's impossible
after this for black to keep the phone
here the
can check give a couple of checks but
it's still a complete draw so I draw a
greedy em yeah this was maybe a slight
slight chance for honor to even gain
another point but it was not like
winning Queen everyone check but it was
just much more tricky to to play okay um
next game is swidler to bar off swidler
is just as only on fifty percent after
this disappointing loss against aronian
yesterday after he has some yeah put so
much oil into the fire that he burned
himself to to use this kind of a
colorful description he could have
easily been on plus two if he had beaten
chronic which was very much possible yet
two polymers on fifty percent if he
wants to yeah get to first place you
need to win a game at some point let's
see what they what they did we had a
ruler pass and two part of us playing
the circuit Miller variation on a side
line which is nevertheless quite
respectable it's very active you see
that he is going for direct play in the
center which srila answers with the
counter-attack right against the bishop
1c5 yet we had this tactical sequence
where both nights got good captures and
now in very interesting flavor black he
just took on f6 and we get a very
unconventional position now with a
wrecked black pawn structure but he has
an extra porn and black has lots of
activity we will see that Bishop b4
Bishop d7 and a four to get play on the
queenside long castles and after a b5 he
played the really interesting news 95
and know that the clock times to pull
off was still in this preparation and it
was very tricky now for swidler to play
you are not well developed and you have
a week back rank and you can easily fall
to hear something like
context for example after Bishop c6 is
probably almost losing my force as you
have this week back rank here he made he
played a good defense I believed at
night Bishop f4 for us I'm sorry Bishop
b5 and then 9283 yeah and around here to
pull off plate a series of moves that
simply am yeah one to run to precise it
seems he had took on d1 the header I
believe concrete idea with that that
simply it didn't work out correctly and
as Bishop e2 seems to be quite okay for
black and I believe leading to yeah to a
good position for black um yeah white
has a hard time here he probably needs
to exchange and in this position black
just has a good initiative and hyster
has this extra porn which is not so
relevant in terms of the porn but this
porn is just an annoying piece near
white skin and it seems to be just a
good position for black what he did
however chat loss exchange and play
Bishop e2 Luke t5 yeah white is just
much more active now in comparison but I
think what he did is he thought that
maybe route g8 what he played was some
was a good active play but it turned out
to be a very problematic one point is
that Luke c5 is just a drawn after that
with Luke f1 Luke f2 but sweeter wasn't
interested in a draw anymore he played
g3 just fighting on and now there's
really this Bishop hanging yeah in term
after well I don't really like what he
did before to pawn off but the next move
is really am almost giving the game away
he took on a three and here Swilley I
had the chance to capture 187 which
seems to almost care win by force
strangely enough he didn't
play it he took on a three it's I mean
the difference to the game is he just
has this h-bond and here black can play
96 to to cover the h7 pawn yeah Bishop
e3 the thing is that this position still
is much more comfortable for white to
play you are porn down okay but all of
black pawns a week yeah and this is the
big problem in the game check at the end
to part of couldn't really defend this
position he had some chances to to hold
it but ultimately after King a six it
probably was a loss King c8 was much
tougher but here we see that White's
rook in combination with the bishop is
getting into an attacking position and
this ultimately he couldn't who would
that's a scroll through this quickly the
thing is all pawns are weak and they
drop one after the other check so at the
end we got to an end game whereas villa
was almost two pounds up this double
porn really doesn't count and at the
ante he won this game with the hub of
the h-bond which jail will promote or
champagne support in checkmating so an
important win for swidler who is back in
the race with plus one well to follow up
with minus one now really will have a
hard time to to stage a comeback he had
a good position out of the opening but
didn't really make much out of it all
right now for the most important game of
Rock kramnik Aronian and a very
complicated game and it's very hard to
to do this in five minutes but i'm going
to try we had a Queens gambit queens in
the entire structure kramnik is not
going for main line
online where many pieces are kept on the
board and this set up that he managed to
get with night on e5 and supported by
those two pawns is very aggressive white
is going for a king site playin King
side attack aronian played an excellent
defense c5 and with Bishop before he
intends to grab the night and then get a
knight to e for himself this is what
happened the night retreated here also
to go to the Kings side but their own
ian now can use this central outpost a
three Bishop f8 and rook t1 was played
yes that's a funny a possibility if
black plays f6 to kick the night white
has Queen takes e4 winning immediately
very funny move check that after this
check wins two minor pieces yeah that he
didn't fall for you played to a six they
form and after those moves white managed
to get an f5 trying to break open the F
file a very dangerous attacker in the
making butter only on that defense
perfectly g5 you are keeping the f are
closed 93 combating this night trying to
get get it exchanged and now he played
b5 aronia did very good defense I
believe in tending the active deployment
of the Queen why took Queen b6 and now
play King Edmund and the idea was shown
in the game King edge 1 he he could also
could have taken on a six but King edge
one is just the more aggressive
attacking move it took on b5 and now
white was able to break open this long
diagonal and this is of course of great
importance as this bishop now is
becoming a very strong piece black
couldn't take on defy
because of 97 yeah something like that
we need to a disaster and tell this is
also not possible Nigel also loses out
right this also hangs so it couldn't
take on d5 and must accept this pawn to
stay on the board but black has a
counter play with these three and yeah
kramnik exchanges the defender with 94
and after h6 still a good move g5 Hanks
place 94 and this is now very very
dangerous in fact black only has got one
defense and Aronian finds it really a
great game played rook c2 and this is
basically a queen second Knight f6 check
until needed to sacrifice the Queen now
to get e to win a great counter play
forking both rooks yeah from nikka now I
must play very precisely aunty he does
so he takes on g5 this is the most
forcefulness you cannot play a passively
you need to continue to attack and here
in exactly this position Aronian made a
mistake he played Bishop takes d5
instead h2 x g5 would have led to a draw
check after this check King edge seven
white will lose one look back and he
does not have enough attacking power it
it is just a draw Bishop d5 however as
uronian plate after Bishop th6 or
Kramnik played king age seven could have
Lee led to to a loss really as Kramnik
now could have played the Moose look g1
and this would have won the game after
taking queen takes white is winning due
to this double attack and if black takes
here why just secures the rook and has a
queen against two bishops black can
still fight a bit but at the end why do
we win this we
the Queen the aconnick decided to take
on a fade and with this check he by
force God Asian descent game which looks
promising for white he's got a pond and
an active King but it turned out that
it's just said wrong Aronian had enough
counter play against the beep on and he
played it precisely i believe check with
this counter play at the end we got a
very typical end game where the f porn
like it's the counterclaim yes they
fought till their kings but check Chad
the end check it was a draw King against
King is really easy to have to analyze
so there was exactly one spot where
kramnik could have won the game here
with luke g1 and yeah certainly a very
very big game I've had kramnik wanted it
would have been entirely different
tournament but this way it's a draw and
it's a wide-open store for for both
players a great game I believe with very
little mistakes in a very complicated
situation yeah I hope you enjoyed this
quick summary if you want to look at the
games in more detail check out the
single game videos thanks for watching